ein technologisches meisterwerk
versunken in einem norwegischen fjord
aus der nähe wird klar er steckt viel
mehr dahinter ein ehrgeiziges bauwerk
das zur gefahr für die umwelt wurde
[Musik]
so was hatte es zuvor noch nie gegeben
das war ein bauliches meisterwerk in der
arktis
ein mysteriöser beton riese auf einem
einzigen berggipfel
da steht dieser wahnsinns bau der wirkt
wie aus einem 70er jahre science fiction
film
und eine bemerkenswerte brook mitten im
hudson river
er hinterließ ein unglaubliches gebäude
das weltweit aufmerksamkeit erregt
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt mit
das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann wurden
diese anlagen aufgegeben manche sind
heute lebensgefährlich verseucht aber
wer hat sie erschaffen und wie und
weshalb wurden sie verlassen
[Musik]
auf dem grund eines norwegischen firma
der hafenstadt narvik liegt ein
vergessenes meisterwerk der
ingenieurskunst
[Musik]
aus den trümmerteilen erhebt sich ein
rostiger elf meter breiter metall koloss
wenn man zum ersten mal diesen haufen
rostigem stahl seht der in diesem
wunderschönen vor ort liegt denkt man da
hätte jemand schrott abgeladen
er erstreckt sich knapp 120 meter
entlang der felsigen ufer des wachstums
und durchbricht dort die
wasseroberfläche aber irgendetwas
scheint dem metall koloss mächtig
zugesetzt zu haben
aus der nähe sieht man wie verbeult und
verzogen dieser rostige stahlhofen nest
ist und dass es sicher nicht nur das
dach von gartenhäuschen ist dass hier
jemand im wasser entsorgt hat kann
sondern dass da viel mehr dahinter
stellen
[Musik]
was hat es mit diesem mysteriösen vag
auf sich warum liegt es in der
unberührten nordischen fitness und warum
ist es verlassen
[Musik]
am ersten märz 1940 auch mit adolf
hitler die invasion des neutralen
norwegen an
er wird sich die lange küste des landes
zu nutze machen und unverzichtbare
rohstoffe für seine wachsende
kriegsmaschinerie gewinnen darunter
hochwertiges eisenerz das vom hafen in
narvik aus verschifft wird
aber in den gewässern dort patroulliert
die britische noch immer die mächtigste
marine flotte der welt
um es mit ihr aufzunehmen braucht die
deutsche kriegsmarine eine moderne
flotte mit schnellen und wendigen
zerstören
[Musik]
stöber sind nicht etwa kleinere
schlachtschiffe sondern praktisch
gebrauchs waffen mit relativ kleiner
besetzung sie sind sehr vielseitig
einsetzbar und unverzichtbar für eine
marine flotte
zerstöre wurden ursprünglich ende des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts als reaktion
auf die aufkommenden torpedo boote
entwickelt während der zwischen
kriegsjahre waren sie leichte schiffe
mit eher geringer reichweite aber stark
gepanzert und zu hohen geschwindigkeiten
fähig sie konnten angriffs konvois
eskortieren worden aber zunehmend als
waffe gegen u boote und flugzeuge
eingesetzt
in den 30er jahren beschließt
deutschland den bau neuer zerstörer und
verstößt damit gegen den friedensvertrag
von versailles
sie entwerfen ein kriegsschiff das den
absoluten gipfel des deutschen technik
könnens repräsentiert und diese
zerstören sollen die besten
kriegsschiffe der weltmeere sein
hitlers floppen zuwachs besteht aus
zerstören der klasse 19 34 ob dies ist
die georg thiele
als damals höchst modernes kriegsschiff
kostet ihr bau fast 14 millionen
reichsmark
1937 wird sie in dienst gestellt
[Musik]
die georg thiele war eines der ersten
neuen kriegsschiffe mit denen hitler den
krieg zur see gewinnen wollte
sie war größer schneller und viel
schwerer bewaffnet als all ihre
potenziellen gegner mobil
am 06 april 1940 machen sich die georg
thiele und neun weitere schwer
bewaffnete hochgeschwindigkeits
zerstörer auf den weg nach narvik der
verband hat insgesamt rund 2.000
gebirgsjäger an bord die speerspitze der
deutschen invasion norwegens
lego christensen schreibt bücher über
die seeschlachten die sich beinahe weg
zu trugen
sie verfügten über sehr fortschrittliche
maschinen
hochdruck kessel versorgten die turbinen
mit hochdruck dampf so dass die
deutschen zerstörer auf
geschwindigkeiten von über 40 knoten
kamen
die englischen zerstörer erreichten
hingegen nur und 32 knoten
trotz ihrer geschwindigkeit und
leistungskraft ist ihr modernes design
unnötig kompliziert und verglichen mit
den zerstörern der royal navy treten
häufig mechanische ausfälle auf die
kriegsschiffe der deutschen waren auf
dem papier ganz hervorragend konnten
sich im einsatz aber einfach nicht
bewähren
hauptmarke des schiffes sein schwerpunkt
liegt zu hoch so dass bei schweren
seegang die stabilität beeinträchtigt
ist um einen kentern zu vermeiden dürfen
die tanks niemals völlig leer gefahren
werden und das ist nicht die einzige
schwachstelle des schiffes
ihr weg war so schwer dass sie bei
seegang richtig ins meer eintauchte und
aberhunderte liter wasser aufnahmen die
maschinen waren unzuverlässig und die
waffen zu machen sind
ihr mächtiges arsenal besteht aus fünf
schiffs kanonen vier 3,7 cm flach
geschossen und 853 3 cm torpedo wurden
trotz der marke ist sie noch immer eine
furchteinflößende kampfmaschine
am 9 april 1940 nehmen zehn zerstörer
kurs auf marik
ihnen gelang ein erfolgreicher
überraschungsangriff auf nahrung und die
invasionstruppen konnten recht schnell
den kopfbahnhof und die stadt einnehmen
und die norwegischen verteidiger in die
flucht schlagen
[Musik]
aber der erfolg ist nur von kurzer dauer
eine streitmacht der royal navy dabei um
nach weg zu befreien
die deutschen kommen mit diesen
hochgerüsteten sportwagen unter den
zerstörern und kriegen es mit den
schwerfälligen land rover mäßigen
zerstörern der reue wie zu tun die
deutschen schlugen sich sehr gut
die georg thiele mischt ordentlich mit
und trägt zur versenkung eines
britischen zerstörers bei
aber in der unterzahl und in der enge
des fjords helfen dem deutschen schiff
seine überlegene geschwindigkeit und
feuerkraft nicht weiter
die georg thiele erleidet siegen schwere
treffer und verliert 14 ihrer 300 25
mann besatzung
man steckt da in einer unmöglichen
situation auch so engem raum kann man
seine torpedos nicht effektiv nutzen und
die briten sind mit kräutern und viel
schwereren schiffen vor ort
die feuerkraft der briten schickt sechs
deutsche zerstörer auf dem grund des
fjords in der falle sitzen und mit
schwindenden munitions und
treibstoffvorräte treten die
verbleibenden deutschen zerstörer die
flucht an die georg tine deckt den
rückzug der drei anderen schiffe und
feuert ihren letzten torpedo auf dem
britischen zerstörer age mss kino ab
[Musik]
der letzte torpedo der georg thiele riss
den bug der eskimo ab
die royal navy nimmt die georg ziele ins
visier
für die es schwer beschädigt keinen
ausweg mehr gibt
[Musik]
ihm blieb nichts anderes übrig als das
schiff so schnell wie möglich aufgrund
zusätzlicher so konnte die besatzung
noch das ufer erreichen bevor das schiff
zerbrach
die mannschaft setzt die georg thiele
auf einen felsen im oxford
[Musik]
das muss schon ein anblick gewesen sein
rund ein drittel des schiffs ragt aus
dem wasser sodass sie cool sich noch
retten konnte aber was für ein opfer die
kapitäne da erbrachten all die
technologie und potenziell ja auch die
gesamte crew
nachdem das schicksal ihres schiffes
besiegelt ist fliegt die besatzung in
die umliegenden berge die schlacht nahe
kommt die deutsche kriegsmarine teuer zu
stehen die hälfte ihrer zerstörer geht
dabei verloren die
georg tiere zerbricht in zwei teile das
heck versinkt in den tiefen des rabatts
für während der bug auf die seite räumt
und verbeult und verlassen liegen bleibt
[Musik]
auch heute noch liegen die überreste des
einst stolzen zerstörers hier in
norwegischen gewässern
die georg thiele konnte ihre
geschwindigkeit wendigkeit und
feuerkraft nicht voll ausspielen
letztlich wurde ihr der austragungsort
der schlacht zum verhängnis
in 20 30 jahren werden ihre überreste
wahrscheinlich weiter zerfallen und
tiefer absenken bis sie sich schließlich
zu ihren schwesterschiffen am
grundgesetz vielleicht ist das ein
passendes ende für die letzte
überlebende aus hitlers längst
versunkener flotte
[Musik]
hoch in den charts mountains im us
bundesstaat alaska steht eines der
ersten baulichen meisterwerke der aktes
der
rostige koloss erstreckt sich in knappen
von 50 metern höhe von einem gletscher
gesunden ufer des kopfüber zum anderen
die länge fast 500 meter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so was hatte es zuvor noch nie gegeben
das war ein bauliches meisterwerk in der
arktis und es ist vielfach kopiert
worden
da war innovatives denken gefragt die
herausforderung ist ja ziemlich
offensichtlich
gestützt wird die stählerne brücke von
drei risiken betonpfeiler je knapp 20
meter lang und am fundament sechseinhalb
meter breit
all das baumaterial hier in die
unberührte wildnis von alaska zu
schaffen ist schon der wahnsinn aber
bei näherer betrachtung fallen
ungewöhnliche bauelemente ins auge die
von den herausforderungen zeugen die bei
der errichtung dieses kurses bezwungen
werden mussten
da sagen diese betonklötze aus dem
wasser warum
[Musik]
wozu dienen diese wertung zacken und
warum steht das scheinbar intakte
bauwerk verlassen da
um 1900 ist ein oscar reich an noch
unentdeckten natürlichen bodenschätzen
tief im gebiet der engel mountains
stoßen rohstoff gräber auf hochwertiges
kupfererz das daraufhin in der neu
gegründeten kennecott mine abgebaut wird
[Musik]
aber damit ist es noch nicht getan wie
sollen sie das wertvolle erz
transportieren die besitzer der mine jp
morgan und der niere guggenheim stecken
25 millionen dollar
die knapp 320 kilometer lange
bahnstrecke muss zahlreiche hindernisse
überwinden die das klima und die
landschaft alaskas mit sich bringen
bauprojekte in der arktis oder der
antrag des sind problematisch
möglicherweise gestalten sie sich im
winter einfacher wenn der boden fester
ist dann gibt es ständig das problem der
schneeschmelze das massenhafte tauwasser
lässt im kurzen sommer die flüsse
anschwellen das alles macht bauprojekte
in solchen gebieten äußerst schwierig
die herausforderungen sind enorm tiefe
schluchten stürmische winde flüsse und
gletscher darunter vor allem details und
der miles gletscher
kaum fünf kilometer voneinander entfernt
blockieren sie die ufer zu beiden seiten
des körpers die einzige lösung bietet
dieses bauwerk die mainz place the
bridge besser bekannt als million dollar
bridge
die million dollar verdient ihren namen
in so vielen hat ihre errichtung
gekostet es war eine nie dagewesene
bauliche herausforderung
lukas bohrer weiß bestens über die
schwierigkeiten während der bauphase
bescheid
die ingenieure mussten völlig neue
techniken entwickeln links und rechts
von der brücke gletscher die tausende
tonnen eis ins wasser kalben dazu winde
mit 160 stundenkilometern und minus 50
grad celsius einfluss mit zehn knoten
fließgeschwindigkeit der sehr schwer zu
erreichen ist
diese praktisch um mögliche brücke muss
leicht genug sein um den fluss zu
überspannen aber auch stabil genug um
der strömung und dem gewicht
vollbeladener züge standzuhalten
[Musik]
um das möglichst ökonomisch zu erreichen
errichten ingenieure vier stahlträger
spannen gestützt von drei betonpfeilern
diese brücke ist eine so genannte
fachwerk brücke die ingenieure lieben
sie wegen der vielen dreiecke dreiecke
sind eine stabile form sodass man
dünnere stahlelemente einsetzen kann die
lasten und wirkenden kräfte werden so
gekonnt ins fundament geleitet und
heraus kommt ein belastbares aber
leichtes konstrukt
der bau der malaysia bridge beginnt im
april 1909 für die arbeiter ist es ein
wettlauf gegen die zeit denn während der
bauzeit stürzen tausende tonnen schwere
eisberge in den fluss die das gesamte
bauwerk mit sich reißen können
innerhalb von nur 13 monaten wird die
brücke fertig gestellt und mit
eisbrechern versehen die die potenziell
zerstörerischen gletscher stücke
aufbrechen sollen
man versucht sie um zu lenken damit
diese riesigen eisblöcken nicht direkt
auf die brücke treffen
es gibt einen eisbrecher vorteile 1 und
einen vierzeiler 3 sie sind beide rund
16 meter lang knapp zehn meter breit
etwa sechs meter tief ins flussbett
eingelassen und tragen rund fünfeinhalb
meter aus dem wasser empor
wenn ein eisberg auf sie trifft
zerbricht er entweder daran oder er wird
abgelenkt so dass er nicht auf die
pfeiler selbst breit
[Musik]
jetzt da die brücke fertiggestellt und
gesichert ist kann 1911 die erste ladung
hochwertigen kupfererz es die fahrt über
die miles gläser bridge antreten
über die nächsten 27 jahre trotz das
bauwerk den elementen und bringt seinen
investoren enorme gewinne ein
[Musik]
auch wenn die million dollar putt zu
ihrer zeit enorm teuer war die mine
brachte um die 200 millionen dollar ein
das rechtfertigte die damals horrende
summe also durchaus
die brücke erweist sich als wichtige und
äußerst profitable verbindung
aber im november 1938 sind die
bodenschätze abgebaut die kennecott mine
wird geschlossen die schienen sollen zu
einer straße umgebaut werden so der plan
doch am 27 märz 1964 und 17 uhr 36 kommt
es zu einer katastrophe
[Musik]
das erdbeben das alaska 1964
erschütterte war laut aufzeichnungen
eines der stärksten beben der
menschheitsgeschichte
ganze siedlungen wurden zerstört
139 menschen sterben bei dem erdbeben
der stärke 9,2
das beben von 64 ließ träger spanne 4
ins wasser stürzen sie war praktisch
unbeschädigt aber der stützpfeiler
darunter war in zwei hälften gebrochen
weil der beton nicht im innern verstärkt
war
die oberfläche des betons ist durch
stäbe verstärkt die senkrecht bis knapp
oberhalb der hochwassermarke verlaufen
so sollen die pfeiler vor eisbergen
geschützt werden
oberhalb dieser stütz stäbe wird der
beton durch die erschütterung des
erdbebens abgetragen
die brücke wird zu einem riesenproblem
sollte auch der rest ein stürzen droht
eine umweltkatastrophe
der koffer river wäre dann nicht nur
blockiert sondern aufgrund der
beschichtung der brücke auch noch
verseucht
ingenieure schwanken lange zeit zwischen
reparatur und abriss des bauwerks aber
letztlich bestimmen finanzielle aspekte
über sein schicksal
[Musik]
reparieren war billiger die abrisskosten
wurden auf über 100 millionen dollar
geschätzt während die erste phase der
brücken reparatur 17 millionen kostete
2004 beginnen die arbeiten um den
beschädigten pfeiler wieder aufzubauen
und die abgestürzte träger spanne zu
richten
[Musik]
trotz der reparaturen ist die brücke nun
überflüssig denn die straße die zu ihr
führt wird aufgrund starker beschädigung
gesperrt die miles grazia bridge wird
aufgegeben
[Musik]
heute ist die brücke lediglich eine
attraktion für touristen und eine
drohende gefahr für die umwelt
sie muss gewartet werden denn ein abriss
wäre zu teuer was also tun die million
dollar britz ist wahrhaftig eine brücke
ins nirgendwo
[Musik]
über 8000 kilometer entfernt auf der
anderen seite des atlantiks steht hoch
in mitten des bulgarischen balkan
gebirges ein gebäude das aus einer
anderen welt zu sein scheint
durch die kühlen nebelschwaden kommt ein
rundlicher betonbau zum vorschein
durchbrochen von länglichen öffnungen
ein verblüffendes bauwerk das ein
bisschen mysteriös wird es erinnert an
einen science fiction streifen aus den
70ern
durch das marode kupferdach fehlt ein
gespenstisches günstiges licht in den
riesigen verlassenen baum
es sieht aus wie ein ufo mit einem
betonmast
der 70 meter hohe turm wer sich zum
boden hin auf nur neun meter breite
verjüngt ragt neben dem beton pro wahl
hervor aber der zweck dieses bauwerks
lässt sich kaum bestimmen
es sei eine kernwaffen kontroll anlage
würde ich es glaubt genauso gut könnte
es aber auch ein heidnisches huldigung
zentrum sein es ist verwirrend
was hat es mit diesem außergewöhnlichen
bauwerk auf sich warum steht es hier in
1400 metern höhe im balkan gebirge
[Musik]
die antwort liegt hinter dem eisernen
vorhang zur zeit der 1970 er jahre
damals ist bulgarien einer der loyalsten
östlichen verbündeten der sowjetunion
dank seines kommunistischen diktators
todor schiwkow
als staatsoberhaupt wählt er sein volk
über die vergangenheit einen ein
aufwendiges projekt soll für heimat
stolz und einigkeit der menschen unter
der kommunistischen versorgen dafür
wählt er einen ort nationalen stolzes
und großer bedeutung
für bulgaren ist das ein bedeutender ort
denn dort fand im neunzehnten
jahrhundert eine schlacht statt zwischen
bulgarischen rebellen aus denen später
die kommunistische partei hervorging und
den streitkräften des osmanischen reichs
neben dem kampf gegen 500 jahre
osmanisches fremdherrschaft und der
gründung der bulgarischen
kommunistischen partei ist dies auf der
ort an den partisanen beim kampf gegen
faschistische truppen im zweiten
weltkrieg ihr leben ließen das alles
macht ihn zu einem nationalen symbol für
heldentum und aufopferungsbereitschaft
und zum perfekten standort für dieses
bauwerk das bus lutherdenkmal
zunächst wirkt dieses denkmal irgendwie
befremdlich denn es ist sehr
ungewöhnlich und einzigartig in keinster
weise ein klassisches denkmal es ist
auffallend seltsam
mutter ist ein gutes beispiel dafür mit
welchen methoden im kommunismus macht
demonstriert wurde diese brutale
überwältigung architektur
am 23 januar 1974 beginnen die arbeiten
aber ein so großes bauwerk auf dem
gipfel dieses unwirtlichen gebirgszugs
zu errichten ist keine leichte aufgabe
etwas so großes in einem abgelegenen
gebiet zu erbauen ist eine
herausforderung aber es war typisch für
das regime zu beschließen wir errichten
den bau genau hier wir schaffen die
materialien auf diesem berg und wir
sprengen die spitze ab so machen wir es
und das taten sie
mehr als 15.000 kubikmeter gestein
werden weggesprengt um den berggipfel zu
geben wodurch der ganze neun meter an
höhe verliert
[Musik]
in dieser arbeitshöhe ist der
baufortschritt enorm von der witterung
abhängig die arbeiter haben mit heftigen
schneefällen starken winden und dichtem
nebel zu kämpfen
sie arbeiten rund um die uhr um das
milde wetter im zeitfenster von mai bis
september voll auszunutzen bei diesem
straffen zeitplan muss das baumaterial
ständig verfügbar sein
es ist aus beton also muss man die
gesteins körnung und den nassen zimmern
dort hoch schaffen das ganze ordentlich
miteinander vermischen und außerdem die
schalung hoch transportieren so dass man
den beton auch in form bringen kann es
ist eine große logistische
herausforderung
70.000 tonnen beton und 3000 tonnen
stahl sind nötig um das bauwerk zu
errichten und seinen kern bildet ein y
förmiges fundament auf dem das gesamte
gewicht des ufo ähnlichen konstrukt
lastet aber
nicht das simple gestaltete innere
sondern die futuristische außenhülle
stellt die größte herausforderung dar
die architektin dora ivanova leitet das
buch lucia projekt ihr ziel ist es das
denkmal wieder aufzubauen und für
kommende generationen zu erhalten
der aufbau des denkmals stellte die
ingenieure in den 70ern vor große
herausforderungen
form und betonhülle wurden von computern
in moskau berechnet
wenn man einen so runden gewundenen bau
errichten will muss man sich überlegen
wie genau man das erreichen möchte das
stellt ingenieure vor eine interessante
herausforderung vor allem damals
derartige rundungen zu schaffen auf die
dann der beton aufgetragen wird
das prinzip gleicht dem eines
umgedrehten regenschirms starke
stahlseile wurden vor gespannt und mit
beton verkleidet um diesen überhang von
25 metern zu erreichen
[Musik]
die futuristische form passt zur
damaligen faszination für die raumfahrt
und zum jubel über den ersten bulgaren
im weltall
beeindruckende 30 tonnen kupfer
verkleiden das dach das beheizt werden
kann um nicht unter schneemassen
einzubrechen
[Musik]
charlie eine der größten
herausforderungen für die ingenieure war
dass das dach enormen schneemengen
standhalten musste
dieser flach abfallende form ist eine
gute lösung denn so kann der schnee nach
unten gleiten und wegrutschen
besonders auffällig der turm willen
richtung himmel emporragt
darin eingelassen sind 212 meter hohe
rote glas sterne mit einem gewicht von
je dreieinhalb tonnen
das waren die größten leuchtenden sterne
der welt man sah sie bei gutem wetter
noch aus 100 kilometer entfernung
auch innen ist das bauwerk imposant
gestaltet
von außen wirkt es wie eine beton
ausgabe eines raumschiffs aber im ist
das ganz anders
mit hilfe von 35 tonnen mosaik und
buntglas sorgten sie für die gewünschte
atmosphäre
[Musik]
die mosaike dienen nicht nur zur
dekoration
jedes element des denkmals soll an die
kommunistische sache erinnern
[Musik]
auf einer seite sah man die gesichter
von lenin marx und engels auf der
anderen die der bulgarischen
kommunistischen anführer
hammer und sichel als 50 quadratmeter
großes mosaik sind im mittelpunkt dieses
enormen bauwerks sieben jahre lang
arbeiten insgesamt 6000 menschen am bus
lutherdenkmal
heute würde es umgerechnet rund 30
millionen euro kosten
zur eröffnung am 23
august 1981 erscheinen die größen des
kommunismus
in der kommunistischen welt wird das
bauwerk als zeichen der macht
glorifiziert
viele kommunistische bauwerke waren eher
einzelpersonen gewidmet oder dem militär
oder der macht der kommunistischen
partei
sie waren nicht unbedingt schön
vielleicht schön auf ihre eigene art
aber da war fraglos eine menge beton im
spiel
es wird zu einem mekka des kommunismus
die besucher sind ritualisiert und
laufen wie organisierte pilgerreisen ab
parallel diente auch als
veranstaltungsort der bulgarischen
kommunistischen partei
die leute waren wirklich beeindruckt von
dem bauwerk und denken noch heute an
ihre besucher zurück bus luther
unterstützte so die kommunistische
mythologie
[Musik]
acht jahre lang dient es als
aushängeschild für den bulgarischen
kommunismus und lockt rund drei
millionen besucher an die sämtlich eine
schriftliche genehmigung brauchen um
hineingelassen zu werden
aber 1989 bricht ein neues zeitalter an
es ist der anfang vom ende der udssr
nacht oder schiff kochs sturz ist das
bus lutherdenkmal nur noch ein relikt
der vergangenheit
die neue regierung hat kein interesse
daran dieses symbol des kommunismus zu
erhalten und lässt es schließen seitdem
ist es verlassen
nach jahrzehntelangem leerstand und
vandalismus ist das bloß lutherdenkmal
heute nur noch eine verfallende höhle
die in nebelschwaden versinkt und seine
zukunft ist ungewiss
am 24 november 2016 er lässt die
bulgarische regierung ein neues gesetz
das die öffentliche zurschaustellung
kommunistischer symbole untersagt
künftige generationen werden
möglicherweise nie erfahren dass hier
einst ein riesiges denkmal des
bulgarischen kommunismus prangte
man kann ja von osteuropäischen
kommunistischen regime halten was man
will aber sie wussten wie man mit
gebäuden eindruck schindet
hinter diesem gebäude steht eine
geschichte es könnte als museum für
bulgarische geschichte dienen und dazu
beitragen
das trauma der kommunistischen
vergangenheit zu überwinden
[Musik]
tief in den wäldern des us bundesstaates
new york verbirgt sich eine abgelegene
insel im hudson river und darauf
scheinen die überreste einer mächtigen
burg zu stehen
die ruine wirkt auf den ersten blick wie
irgendein schloss an einem see in
schottland
die ruinen erstrecken sich über die
insel im schutz von bäumen zahlreichen
rollen und türmen wie sie für paläste
oder mittelalterliche burgen typisch
sind ausgestattet mit zinnen und
schießscharten
was war ihr zweck das erschließt sich
aus der schrift an einer der mauern
was sollte dieser beeindruckende
festungsbau schützen und warum wurde er
aufgegeben
im jahr 1900 betreibt der millionär und
geschäftsmann frances ballermann der
sechste ein erfolgreiches unternehmen
mit militär überschüssen im herzen von
new york city sein geschäft am broadway
nimmt fast an den gesamten block 1 aber
er braucht ein lagerhaus das groß genug
ist um seine gesamte explosive ware
darin unterzubringen darunter auch etwa
30 millionen patronen die aus dem
spanisch amerikanischen krieg von 1898
übrig geblieben sind der captain ist
geschäftsführer des benjamin kessel
trust der sich für den erhalt der
anlagen einsetzt er dürfte in der stadt
kein schwarzpulver lagern bald schon
eine kleine menge davon ein gesamtes
gebäude springen kann
die lösung findet sich 80 kilometer von
new york city entfernt im hudson river
auf einem unbewohnten stück land das
manchen stämmen amerikanischer
ureinwohner als verwunschen gilt
hollande
[Musik]
männern soll das felsige ein land für
600 dollar gekauft haben um dort seine
explosive ware zwischenzulagern
daraus wird letztlich diese mächtige
festung das band silent arsenal besser
bekannt als benz cars
es ist weder eine schottische burg noch
ein britisches herrn haus oder ein
verfallenes französisches chateau das
ist ein munitionslager
es ist nahe genug in new york um die
geschäfte am laufen zu halten aber auch
weit genug entfernt um keine gefahr für
die bevölkerung darzustellen bennemann
will der insel seiner eigenen note
verleihen und macht sich selbst an die
entwürfe
[Musik]
er war hobby architekt es gab keine
baupläne er zeichnete einfach auf
servietten oder zettel er gab
anweisungen wie sie es bis hierhin und
wenn es ihm nicht gefiel hieß es reißen
sie es noch mal ab und bei uns sie ein
fenster ein so lief das
die arbeiten beginnen im frühjahr 1901
mit der sprengung von tonnen von fels um
das fundament für das dreistöckige
lagerhaus zu ebnen
[Musik]
die geschäfte florieren und mit ihnen
der bau von dämmen silent
1905 kommen zwei weitere gebäude und ein
hafendamm hinzu um das wachsende waffen
imperium unterzubringen
anstatt auf eine simple gestaltung setzt
berner man auf eine sehr kunstvolles
äußeres
inspiration bezieht er dabei aus seiner
familiengeschichte
käme ich zufällig an batmans kassel
vorbei und wusste nicht wo ich mich
befinde würde ich aufgrund der
klassischen stein bauweise und des burg
ähnlichen aussehens annehmen ich sie
irgendwo in nord schottland
unser moment
warum das gebäude so entwarf na ja er
war ein stolzer schotte und ehrte so
sein heimatland also bediente er sich
alle elemente die das bauwerk noch mehr
wie eine burganlage wirken ließen
der exzentrische millionär greift zu
ungewöhnlichen methoden für die
hafenanlage versenkt er mehrere mit
schrott und schutt beladene kenne um so
das fundament zu legen
frank werner mann war in praktisch
denkender geschäftsmann der sein geld
damit verdiente schrott zu verkaufen und
verschwendung war ihm ein fremdwort was
ich nicht verkaufen ließ nutzte er
selbst von alten nach tischen bis hin zu
bauteilen von schlachthöfen nutzt er
alles um die gebäude zu verstärken
banons sparkurs ist an den bauten
sichtbar
das gebäude besteht aus einer wilden
mischung unterschiedlichster
baumaterialien mit etwas backstein und
einer sehr dünnen betonschicht drumherum
das klingt schon für ein wohnhaus
äußerst fragwürdig aber darin
sprengstoff zu lagern halte ich für eine
wirklich haarsträubende idee
[Musik]
dennoch lagert hier 1908 eine der
größten privatsammlungen vom militär
überschüssen und munition die es je in
den vereinigten staaten gegeben hat
berlin ist in dieser hinsicht ein
pionier
[Musik]
überschüsse aus armeebeständen werden
heute an jeder ecke angeboten wegen
ballermann er kaufte auf wofür sich
sonst niemand interessierte und schon
bald bezogen hollywood und der broadway
ihre requisiten von ihm
[Musik]
rennens militärische ausrüstung und
uniformen kommen auf bühnen und an
filmsets zum einsatz um seiner braut
anlage und ihren schätzen noch näher zu
sein verbringt bernem die sommer mit
seiner familie auf der insel aber die
laienhafte konstruktion der bauwerke
ergibt in kombination mit der explosiven
ware die hill gelagert ist eine tickende
zeitbombe
man sieht dass da kein meister seines
fachs am werke war es hat er so was von
marke eigenbau das macht es so spannend
aus der ferne wirkt es beeindruckend
nicht mehr so sehr
[Musik]
ich finde es großartig aus metallschrott
und anderen materialien etwas ganz
fantastisches zu erschaffen aber für
gebäude würde ich das nicht empfehlen
denn wenn man darin wohnen will sollte
es stabil sein ich würde da nicht
einsehen wollen
berlin vergrößert die anlage durch
weitere gebäude bis er 1918 stirbt und
das geschäft an seine ehefrau helen
übergeht
am 15 august 1920 kommt es zur
katastrophe
seine frau helen berna mann saß am haus
in ihrer hängematte und den rhein um
sich einen tee zu holen als sie sich
umdrehte flog ein gebäude in die luft
und teile der trümmer stürzten genau auf
die hängematte in der sie gerade gelegen
hatte
es gehen fast 100 kilogramm
schwarzpulver im lager hoch und
schleudern einen acht meter langen mauer
abschnitt über den fluss und auf die
bahngleise
das waffenlager wird größtenteils
zerstört doch das privat schloss
übersteht die gewaltige explosion
im laufe der jahre geht das geschäft
elements zurück und auch die bauwerke
auf der insel werden zunehmend baufällig
[Musik]
1969 besiegelt ein verheerendes
tagelanges feuer ihr schicksal das
batman kasse wird aufgegeben
[Musik]
heute sind die ruinen gesichert und
benjamin silent ist zur beliebten
touristenattraktion geworden im angebot
geführte touren theateraufführungen und
filmnächte
frances benjamins fantastische
burganlage fasziniert ihre besucher noch
heute er hat hier einen unglaublichen
bau hinterlassen der weltweit
aufmerksamkeit erregt die leute kommen
her und fragen nach bennemann island
die bennemann anlage ist zweifellos
baufällig und dürfte millionen
verschlingen aber ich finde das ist es
wert denn dass es ein stück geschichte
das meines erachtens nicht in
vergessenheit geraten sollte
[Musik]
heute sind sie verlassen aber sie
zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt
diese verfallenden konstruktionen sind
ein echo der vergangenheit sie erzählen
von krieg und schrecken aber auch von
entdeckergeist und
fortschritt
[Musik]